there are three starting players on
cloud9's valorant roster right now and
their first match in VCT Americas is a
little over two weeks away if you're a
Cloud9 fan like myself then you're
probably freaking out right now so
what's going on
[Music]
spring is right around the corner and
you might be looking for some new
threats so head to shop.thescore.com and
check out our Esports collection I
promise you'll love it over the past few
weeks Cloud9 has made some well
interesting decisions following their
loss to DRX at VCT lock-in valorent
reporter Puris tweeted on February 23rd
that yay would no longer be part of c9's
active roster now obviously this news
shocked everyone sure Cloud9 got
embarrassed by DRX but you can't pin
that loss on just one player if anything
the comps that they picked were
questionable to say the least and they
had absolutely no answer for the Viper
Harbor combo on icebox so when I first
heard this news I was disappointed as
someone who has supported C9 as an org
for nearly 10 years seeing the valent
roster make changes after only one real
event was worrying and on March 1st it
became official one of the big things
addressing you know the role issues that
have you know been around Cloud9 even
before I came here we are still trying
to figure those things out and so we're
more so looking forward towards the
future of the team with everything that
we need to try to correct some of these
things because you know comps are going
to keep changing metas are going to
change and uh you know flexibility and
role issues are something we need to
continue to look forward to like
addressing and fixing as the team goes
on now although it may seem like an
insane decision this is not the first
time Cloud9 has done something like this
if you're a fan of League of Legends
then you may remember last year when C9
dropped their head coach LS after only
four games in charge cloud9's CEO jacket
Tien also gave us more PR speak in that
video and suggested that they just
didn't see eye to eye with ls but didn't
really say much else and following this
most recent announcement C9 got roasted
by their Community again yay even posted
this tweet that has since been deleted
where he said role issues were
definitely the reason for me departing
and the team coach definitely agreed
with me being removed many have
interpreted this tweet as sarcasm
especially after yay deleted it and he
still hasn't addressed it further but to
play a devil's Advocate cloud9's role
issues have been a problem for quite a
while since they traded Zeta and Autumn
to T1 for curry back in May of last year
things have sort of been a mess I
genuinely miss the days where my boy
Sunny was slinging darts across the map
and fragging out on agents like soba and
breach for many C9 fans those were the
golden days so when did it all go wrong
if you ask me Zeta and Autumn leaving
for T1 was the Turning Point Cloud9
failed to make an International Event
all of last year I was excited when I
heard that C9 was signing yay in the off
season but I mean who wouldn't be
excited if their team signed the best
player in the world the problem is that
it still didn't solve the underlying
issues within the team and this is not
to throw shade at yay or the rest of the
roster we all know that they're great
players but cloud9's issues were swept
under the rug when they announced their
2023 roster and now yay is in an awful
position he only has a couple weeks to
find a new team and there's a good
chance that he doesn't even end up on a
partnered roster this year and if you're
a fan of valorent that sucks but c9's
announcement this past weekend makes
things look a lot worse for the orc
purist reported on Vanity's departure
back on March 6th but yesterday it
became official even after George
reported that Vanity's teammates wanted
him to stay I reached out to both vanity
and Cloud9 to try and get more info but
I haven't heard back at the time of
recording this so for now just like
everyone else I'm forced to speculate on
what role issues really means if you ask
me C9 did have role issues but that
doesn't mean that you drop yay
even if the chamber meta is long gone
yay still took Envy to a Masters final
while playing Jet and even if Cloud9 is
suggesting that yay didn't have a deep
enough agent pool then I still don't
think it's fair to drop him after one
Mickey Mouse event and two matches at
lockhan many people have suggested that
this entire situation was caused by
Financial issues to which Jack responded
on the C9 subreddit stating that the org
is in a great place financially and he
aims to keep it that way by controlling
costs in a time where sponsorships are
tight and that he's planning for the
long term but just yesterday the Esports
Advocate reported that Cloud9 has let go
members of their video production and
content creation team the valorant
roster is currently trialing tier 2
players as replacements for both yay and
vanity because the org is allegedly not
willing to pay buyouts for players under
contract with partner teams and
according to slasher C9 only replaced G2
in the VCT America's League after Carlos
showed public support for Andrew Tate
Cloud9 was actually the final team on
the bubble really they almost didn't get
it tells me that Cloud9 replaced G2 not
EG so despite everything we've been told
about Cloud9 these past few weeks I'd be
naive to think that there isn't more to
this story and although Jack is telling
us otherwise perhaps Financial issues
are causing problems I already feel bad
for the players and everyone else this
team is supposed to play their first
match in the new era of the VCT in a
couple of weeks but I worry that this
might only be the start of something
worse
because I did something insane on old
school RuneScape last night I'm about to
get my primordial Crystal
[Music]
Jordans
no way what the no what the
what the yo what the